I look at some Harris and then I flick
discussion I think there's a thinker and
there's somebody who's not thinking they
both think of themselves as liberals
some Harris spends his days and hours
and time thinking so he's been following
these things for a very very long time
I do not know Ben Affleck I've seen very
little of his work I think he's a
brilliant actor and I think he is a
leading figure in the United States of
America but it's absolute absolutely
clear he hadn't given a thought to this
then we have to be able to criticize bad
ideas and of course we didn't own the
rule doesn't work okay but is why what
is the mother lode of bad ideas she so
we have it we have my Anatomy it is ugly
pasta see I will give him one point
which is this so Mohammed an individual
who is influencing over one-fifth of
humanity is the only really historic
figure we cannot draw anymore we can't
discuss him without seeing peace be upon
him so a very powerful historical figure
a historic figure whose power comes into
the 21st century and is upsetting
geopolitical structures would Ben
Affleck play the part
he can play Batman what would he play
Muhammad and the answer to that question
tells me he needs a second chance to
think these things through any actor in
Hollywood who is very successful who is
not willing to act that part
should not go around making accusations
of bigotry to others I'm not denying
that that certain people are bigoted
against Muslims as people that right and
that's a problem big of you but the
white we hope about this it is gross
it's racist it's not it's but it's only
so it's like saying those Oh Nate you're
shifty Jew you're not Leslie not we are
saying let's go back to the time of
communism there were people who went
around making excuses for communism
because they didn't know about the gulag
and when they found out about the gulag
they found out about what communism
actually led to they were saying we were
right in our hearts even though you were
wrong with our heads is that where we
are with this alarm today and liberalism
Islamic extremism is an assault on the
ideas of liberalism on the idea of
innovation on women on gays on tolerance
on civilization
you may choose not to see it and bury
your head in the sand it's a choice you
may choose not to say anything about it
it's a choice when you attack the people
who actually stick their heads out and
accuse them of bigotry again the scene
of a Ben Affleck accusing a Sam Harris
of bigotry that tells me do you really
know what you're saying it's almost like
giving a child a timeout you know just
don't I it's like Ben you're a great guy
go and rethink this and go and think go
and think